Merhaba
[Müzik]
Hoş geldin
çok heyecanlı çok büyük bir olur
dağıtım için
organizasyonundan
çok teşekkür ediyorum o
[Müzik]
abone ol
Bu
çizgi film Aslında çok büyük bir bir
okumamız bitireceğim ve
rakamları ama bana da şöyle söyleyeyim
dünyada şu anda
20 birilerine göre b Haydi önemlidir ve
eğlence sektöründe
animasyonda o
[Müzik]
var ancak sadece rakamları mı deldi
grafiklerine bakacağız Hayır animasyon
her ne kadar bile olsa da Aslında
insanı insan yapan hikaye anlatmayı
patlıyor Ben sizi Şimdi iki tane harika
insanlarla tanışmak istiyorum Benim
hayatımda Önemli olan
dedim Ben küçükken ya da yazdı ya
[Müzik]
O yanlış oldu resmini yine Anneannenin
anneanneleri Bu ağırlığı yılların olmasa
da başkasıyla görünce resim yapma
yolunda bizim bir cevabıdır çünkü sahibi
görüyor yaptığım bir şey saygı görüyorum
da
aynı
çizimleri araba alıyorlar ve hangisinin
bu
hareket ediyor musun
koyabiliriz ben duvar duymak bize vermiş
koyabilirsiniz denemeleri aynı Oğlum
benim için hani o
kendimizi ifade etme mutfağımı arttıran
çok önemli bir şey olumlu bir güçlü ve
hop koyduğumda hayatım boyunca sabah da
ilgilenirken sanatın meslek var
bana destek olan zahmet ve o
[Müzik]
abone
olalım yani ettiğin ders işte bir yerde
Yardım günümüz geri oyun sektörü
animasyon içinde çok hiçbir şekilde var
oldu sana gerçeklik yazdığı bir parçası
ve
bahsediyoruz yine animasyonlu da çok
önemli bir yerde duruyor
karşılaştığımız bir şekilde o
[Müzik]
ve
Edebiyatçılar arkadaşlar yapıyor hepsini
hocaları paradan bahsetmiyorum
arkadaşlar
Evet şimdi buradan bahsettiği için şey
yapamıyorum Yani yazacağıma mıyız filmin
çekilmesi için manevi emaneti birşey
olması gerekiyor
Sadece
konuşma ama aslında o
[Müzik]
var ya Phone yapabilen kız olarak
tanımlıyor
hep vardı yapan kadınlar evde işi de
idare eden hazırlayıp vardı şimdi
verdim kavramlar geleceği
için de oyunda var sinemada var bir de
[Müzik]
ve
ekonomik ve kültürel değer olduğu
anlaşıldı için yani bu nevi destek O da
anlaşıldığı için desteklenmeye başladı
15'te
sadece
hizmet anlamında mı
[Müzik]
bu
sayısını olduğunca azaldığını görüyorum
bu niye doğru insan sorgulama sorgulama
alıyorum şimdi 2019'da
Avrupa görsel ve
[Müzik]
ne yapacağız katılanlar Bir de 27
sırasında öğrencilerden saldırmış Şimdi
ben de gördüğünüz animasyon ile birlikte
yaptığımız götürdü Altın Portakal o
[Müzik]
abone ol
Oy
kurban eti getirdi ve animasyon
arkadaşlar var oldukları için araçlar
var böyleyim
o zaten içinde
gidelim
yaratıcılığı artık çok güzeldi artık
parasız tozu olunca kadınları
sorgulandığı bir dönemdeyiz
yollarda
zor o
[Müzik]
çok küçük
küçük
şimdi bu
sorgulamadan Sonra dedim ki bir sürü
kadın var yani yaratıcı başarılı mı
da getirmedim
Bu
nasıl dünyasına bakın Başkanlığı kurucu
başkanı olan teklif edildi bölümü
kendimi güçlendirmek için başarılı
takımımız başarıyorlar animasyon
sektöründe sordunuz takımlar ve
buhar
yaptım bunları yer aldı animasyon ve
[Müzik]
Ne diyorlar
Evet şimdi fikir değiştirirsin
O benim annem
Allah rahmet eylesin tarihte bir insandı
ve bana bir sürü adam var mı
[Müzik]
O Kadınları bir İşe başvururken bir iş
tanımının tamamını karşılıyor varsa
artık verme tamam başlıyorlar sana o işi
bağımsız balıkları
araştırmalar ya da
erkeklerden Eğer ben bir şeyleri vardı
yüzde yirmi az başlıkları ortaya çıkmış
düşünüyorum da
[Müzik]
ben size Aslında bu kadınların da hatası
olarak bize kendini sevdiğim olarak
adlandırdığımız
doğru olanı yapmalıyım mı
[Müzik]
Evet şimdi
bu müzik yer var İtalya kalbim yanıyor
bir yazarım görünmez kendisini bir
kitabından size kesinlikle öğreteceğim
Bu kitapta o
bu YouTube
çok yazıyor çok büyük taş taş ama nerede
teyze aldı Hep kişi daha buraya da sabit
düşüyor ya var bu
taş bu o
Evet şimdi bu bu sektörde O elbiseler bu
hayatta hep beraberiz Herkesin bir
değeri var
Yalçınkaya ortak bunu yazmam noktasıyla
annemin burada biraz çıkıyor Çünkü
Yalçın kollukları Biz kendimiz
geçirseniz elbisemiz Bir de aslında
Yanımızdaki insanlarla geçiriyorsunuz
animasyon
[Müzik]
çok hızlıca size bir animasyon
animasyon tarihine
taşlarından hızlıca bahsetmek istiyorum
tabii ki Karagöz
bu 700 yıllık bir geçmişe sahip
görüyoruz
sinema yapan üzerinizden biri
tarihimizin bir parçası animasyon böyle
Türkiye'de gösterilen mi
abone ol
[Müzik]
Ne
istediniz
Türkiye'de yapılan
animasyonlarında sahipleri cevap Nadir
Güler'in amca beni plajda
yok bilmiyoruz ki
bu
kişilik bir sinema gibi animasyon gibi
üzerinde çalışır kişi şuanda İstanbulda
çalışıyor
yapmaya çalışmışlar
ve şimdi
göreceksiniz bayağı demek bayağı mı
bu Mahmut nerelerde öldü
dünyanın dört bir tarafında harika bir
bu olaylar yazdım izi kaldı şu anda
neler ama kadar hadi neler gençlerin
sevdiği Onun dışında Fransa'dan Kore'den
Japonya'dan Amerika'dan adam ol
bir
şeyler
kanallar Şu anda misafir yapamadım ama
yetişkin ya da gençler için Aslanlar
gösteren kanallarda
yetişkinler ve siz animasyonlar Çünkü o
abone ol
Bu
da
çok izleniyor bir seviyorum
ilk
denemelerde yapılıyor ama yine de bu
denemeleri yaparken biraz alayım bakayım
kötü hikayeler yüzünden getirdim
davranıyoruz para getirmiyoruz ekipler
buralarda zorlana biliyoruz ama burada
bu işi hakkını vere ve deneye ve devam
yüreği ve insanlarla
bu animasyon kurumlarımız var hayırlısı
derneklerimiz var meslek birliklerimiz
var Bu harika bir şey daha iyi eğlenmek
yaz görselde tek ya animasyon
sanatçıları terliği gençlerde kaplamak
istiyorum
bunun dışında
yayınlarımız var şimdi
araştırmada yapılmalı tarihçe-i
Ha bir de tabii hiçbir zamanı gelir
yaptırmamız gereken kimse Deniz gereken
sosyal medyadan sosyal mecralar var
YouTube var yemeği vardı kavramlar o var
mı yapılan yayınlar var
bireyler olarak beğenir gerçekleştiren
animasyon zararlar var Çok mutlu oldum
çünkü
ya ben de bireysel değil biz ekip olarak
Hatta bir sürü durumunda desteğini
alarak
gerçekleştiren ıslanmaması yakın ormanın
dile biri olarak da karşınızda
bulunuyorum ücretsiz animasyon Eğitimi
ve üretimini teşvik eden bunun için alt
yapı oluşturan bir platform
bu birinci belgemizi ağladım arkamıza
aldık çünkü farklı bırakmak istiyoruz
kütüphanemizi kuruyoruz
YouTube'da bazı yayınlar yapıyoruz
animasyonla ilgilenen insanlara saygı
geçirdiği herkese seslenen girişimlerde
bulunuyor
34 gençliğin belki de en çok rahat etti
Bence davet etmeniz gereken çok çizgi
roman harika bir şeydir çizgi roman
yarışması düzenledik Buna devam etmek
sözü çizgi romanları basacağız gerçekten
kitap olmaktan da okusun diye yazıyoruz
Evet şimdi bütün bu öykünün de uzun öyle
Aslında
kapsayıcı olmak
yapma yapabilmek Bu yüzden kadın gibi
yapalım diyorum yapıp gelirim istiyorum
o
şekilde
şefkatli şekilde insanlara bu şekilde
işin sadece ekonomik değil ruhsal
borcunu düşünerek herkese animasyonu
katalım ve
bu harika bırakmak istiyorum ya
[Müzik]
bu animasyon sevdiğine tarif etmem yeni
yetenekler yetiştirmek üzere yola çıktı
ve ve öyle görünüyor bir gelecekte
Türkiye'nin geleceğinde umut var daha da
güzel günler çok teşekkür ediyorum şu